so during class I like to take a few
minutes of break so so that that will
allow the students to take some rest
because when you ready the country is so
intense such that people it takes some
time for the students to actually digest
and to understand the concepts covered
in the first part of the lecture and
also it gives them an opportunity to
interact with me and that usually during
the break they bring a lot of questions
which we didn't anticipate before there
are many many questions about
mathematics and also physics concepts
here you have del square e right and the
term square you have one two three turn
three operators and you are good you if
you write everything explicitly so
basically you this operator is going to
be operating on e x ey + ZZ and we can
actually solve them during the class and
I can even cover part of the the
question asked during the break so that
everybody actually can benefit from
those interesting questions people
before I should bring up during the
break